ooh
[Music]
those goodness
[Music]
good morning Millennials we need to work
on the third part yeah but that would be
a great theme song for us that was just
improv you know but that would be a
great theme song for us it would good I
don't spoil it
yeah we love to work on it we'll take it
day by day I hear it again let's tune in
five
good morning Monday happy Monday it is
just like so Monday right now it's so
Monday I feel like we've been like like
shot Jay and we haven't had like a real
Monday in like three weeks in to be here
in like Turks and Caicos Monday last
week today we didn't it's just men these
are tough they're less tough when you
have the morning toast so I'm happy for
you guys thank you guys the first it's
treacherous nonetheless it's so truly
treacherous and I am like so physically
mentally spiritually and like
metaphysically exhausted still uh-huh I
did not go out Saturday night which is
like the first Saturday night I haven't
like gotten blackout drunk in like I
think here
well that's because you did it on Friday
yeah usually you saying that's true um
so Thursday Friday with the shows so
many people came out it was just unreal
like energy it really was
we did two sugars break once again frat
house it was someone threw up on
themselves okay like that is the vibe we
were going for Thursday night we did two
shows Friday night we did two shows and
it was just like everyone was wasted
and everyone was so cute and fun and
like down and wear dress do you know
what I mean well and good smelling yeah
it's a good smelling button it was just
really fun it was really great they went
so well I'm so glad they are over now I
have a pin about the Nashville show
which is gonna be so fun with fun it's
gonna outweigh the pit of course of
course but like and I'm so excited to
like meet national toasters I feel like
we've seen the New York toasters a bunch
of times ya know there were a lot of
familiar faces and I love them but it's
10% it's time to meet some national
history unfortunately our toasts show is
sold out sorry but there are a couple
tickets left for my solo show which is
like so sad for me but whatever it's a
one-woman show on Broadway again oh my
god you can only go to City Center have
a Broadway but when I do think I was
making a joke well actually Jackie made
it that like I was doing a one-woman
show on Broadway because getting
Broadway it's literally on the
Caroline's on Broadway we were just like
meeting the joke that I was doing a
one-woman show and like when you go to
the Geo fiddles filters on snapchat it's
a Broadway like you are Peter district
your show on Broadway and so we're doing
Nashville and national they have a
street like a pop and you called
Broadway and I think zany is mean he's
like off of its off-broadway in bed
study I can only perform in cities that
have like the Broadway or like even if
we go to like Chicago we need to find
like a street called Broadway
there's red dye house there and do our
show there's Broadway everywhere there
has to be there is you could do a show
of Monopoly well we're really excited
that's gonna be June 5th and our shows
June 6 and then we're hitting up cma
fest hard like i am hitting cma fest
hard like i will probably need to take
the week off t take the week off after
cma fest by the way I'm down for that
like because first of all there's
nothing relaxing even though it's
technically like leisure because we're
going on our own anything like sometimes
you go on like a vacation like
technically we're taking vacation but
there's nothing that leash a leash in
America it's a work trip CMA fest I've
never been but I imagine it to be
extremely difficult but also rewarding
between like the singing the drinking
the walking the part like everything
between being the first monster in
general is like an extreme workout so
I'm just letting you know I'm so skinny
yeah all those thirsty girls are so
skinny because they're always just like
working out running from place to place
no I know I'll call mr. skinny because
like I was working out so much during my
show so I was like pacing and like
walking and like I felt I literally woke
up so skinny
you need to start wearing a Fitbit
during your show I know just to like see
just to see how many steps you're doing
because you're I definitely the
physicality you are been flat in
encumber by in comic form okay as always
Jackie and I are here to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I want a piece of
morning toast so badly
also a few housekeeping updates
everyone's asking us to talk about
Riverdale because you did finally catch
up let's talk about it a little bit but
then we came up with an idea which I
think will be fantastic because we need
to get the squad back together the after
Dale squad a term we can't actually use
easily so post after Dale
thus after Dale Saturday lists us Ben
and snitch but Ben isn't caught up no
but anyway so
after the season finale on Wednesday
maybe we'll all watch together on my new
couch I mean if you would like your
buffering like a baby we're watching
nevermind I don't even have I can't even
watch on my ass and then on Thursday
we're gonna do a podcast episode of
after Dale with the squad talking about
the whole season so that podcasts or a
patreon patreon podcast I'm sorry on our
patreon channels so that it will live
there impressed arity and you bastard
like the seven diehard after Dell fan
said you can buck up the pay eight
dollars of course yeah those seven
master Dell fans like they're devastated
- let me tell you I caught up on
Riverdale on Saturday so after my four
shows I was truly exhausted
I pulled like a boss move and took my
comforter to the couch like that's the
move all day I had like ten I didn't
realize how far behind I was like I
hadn't watched it since our break
because like during the break I'm like
I'm not watching after to hell it's too
painful you know yeah and then I just
never like got back up so this is the
thing expectations were set super high
for me swells obviously letdown because
like I the way everyone made it seemed
like the whole cast died do you know
what I mean yeah but so I was loving
some of the like the more less recent
episodes like where Cheryl gets put in
that terrible place and like it was so
sad and she was being such a good
actress like moving those sandbags like
that was premium acting yeah that's like
beyond CW that's oscar-worthy Lilly
Reinhardt everyone Lilly right heart
should be nominated for an Emmy by the
way I was thinking when Madeline pitch
was doing that I'm like why is it a show
nominated for an Emmy all of these all
of them are supreme actors also except
Marisol Nichols they're all decent also
like I can't tell if Mark Consuelos is a
good actor we're like he's a notch
higher lodge he said yes and so I don't
know that I struggle with that also I my
favorite character which is so crazy
because I used to be I heard Cheryl I'm
like I'm okay Cheryl is Veronica which
is crazy because in the beginning of
hazzard oh we used to rail on her yeah
gross but this is the thing like why did
higher logic like have to ruin it things
were going so well like Veronica and
Artie were gonna be like the mob popular
like Malcolm I mean like he was deep
down he got a car like them riding in
that car like I was shup and I was like
you know what [ __ ] you Fred and she was
like you can't provide a life for Archie
that he needs like and I was so down and
then
like harmony like take it too far and
now like everything's ruined
yeah he got too cocky that look that was
in a way and I was just like loving
Veronica Archie I should've Archie the
most I ship hard core Alyce Caron FP
I don't oh my god they are so cute he's
a real man
oMG like no they're perfect I think
Alice Cooper is like the unsung hero of
the entire show she's absolutely always
said that she's unbelievable like I
actually like loved how until oh my god
how was always you guys Meghan Markel
has kissed how good yeah the black hood
why because they were in a hallmark
movie together where he was playing her
boyfriend that she won't like her big
city slicker boyfriend who she wound up
leaving for her small town that's not
age-appropriate
well whatever Meghan Marco has kissed
that actor Meghan Merkel has kissed a
black hood which isn't the only shady
thing she's done this week yeah we'll
get to it one more thing I want to say
about afternoon I mean River doesn't
make like notes crazy that he wound up
being like the biggest terror TV
character Billy America also gives us
the princess also gave a fake [ __ ] to
what the actor's name Ted from [ __ ]
scream right yeah so like that was years
ago she also did a lot of other crazy
things like in her past but this is just
the most recent thing it was one more
thing I want to say about Riverdale Oh
like them saying that black hood is how
and then like there's another black hood
that's such like a pretty little liar
it's like that you a is like just tell
us that's what someone literally said in
the comments but I do think there's only
one more and I think it's either that
theory that how has a twin because
almost blossoms are twins and they
obviously are blossoms or that it's
Claudius okay that's what Jacob said
also one more thing I want to say
Veronica does she have the darkness
because members she would but right
before she punched Reggie she did the
thing she did yes
so I'm telling you I think she might be
like a blossom Cooper when did she she
when he was saying terrible things about
her family in the hallway and she was
running for student body president right
she did it and then I thought she was
gonna release but then she punched him
she might have the dirt or maybe she's
just like was angry like Arthur Arthur
yeah like this has meaning don't [ __ ]
with us it does have meaning
oh it chick shucks
all of it it's so crazy also dynasty
season finale I don't want I got snitch
into it you need to watch it's amazing
it's Gossip Girl myself in so far it's
so worth it and I keep like paralleling
what happened in the dynasty season
finale and it's just amazing and every I
think dynasty will be like we're nowhere
it's on Netflix like tomorrow and you
can all watch it over the summer and
really everyone should because it's so
well done everyone is so beautiful and
the plot just really keeps twisting I
just I support Liz Gillies so like I'll
think about it and she's never been so
beautiful okay and she sings a little
she's just she's a good thing she's a
CEO like amazing it's really really
amazing I just like watching rich people
like watching poor people's soda brown
know and it's like even when they're
going through troubles or like someone
takes all their honey like they still
have more money no betray and they still
have like a house no it's like it's it's
nice to watch like those kinds of
problems I totally agree you know
well let's jump into the first story
okay because this is the craziest story
I've ever seen and I personally feel
victimized Megan Marcos I felt her I
felt I fell victim to mr. Markel yeah
because I came on the show and I said
when you look up here in the dictionary
you see a picture of Megan Marcos dad
reading a book about London mm-hmm
meanwhile in a strategically placed
window meanwhile Megan Marcos shameless
dad is accused of faking photos ahead of
the Royal Wedding
basically CCTV security footage came out
this weekend of him staging pictures
with a photographer of him in an
internet cafe but she was like here we
have the picture for you let's just so
the photographer this is a picture that
went viral of like him being cute
looking at his daughter and her fiance
on the Daily Mail in an Internet
category like oh my god this is so
precious again someone caught a picture
of Megan markle's dad just like being
precious and pure and then the truth was
uncovered 10 our next photo we have the
set up of said photo is it up yeah the
first photo is that is going on look at
that heresy
trader jump Tomas Marko worked with LA
based celeb snapper Jeff Rainer on the
phony photos which were peddled as
supposedly candid shots the Daily Mail
on Sunday said sighting witnesses and
CCTV footage the picture showed showed
Thomas Marcos 73
hangout new reports about his daughter's
wedding and an internet cafe reading a
magazine about British landmarks and
even being fitted for a suit for his
daughter's wedding to Prince Harry on
Saturdays we invited guess he's walking
her by London yet I don't know maybe he
is now this was like last night he's
walking her down the aisle like he's
shamed he should be hanging his head in
DeMarcos have brought nothing but shame
to the Windsor family like between the
half brother who was like in jail the
system open letter the sister the half
sister who's like Harry Megan doesn't
really love you the only normal one is
her mom like she and her band of
yellow-bellied losers have brought
nothing but shame to the royal family
and like I couldn't be living for it
anyway
witnesses reported seeing the dad and
Raina show up together and plan out the
scenes in three photoshoots they didn't
stay long probably about 10 minutes the
internet cafes manager Jessica and I a34
told the Daily Mail okay so I guess we
know who leaked the photos no totally
but like if you're gonna do something so
like strategic like doing it in like a
non public like 100 people that's the
point like he had to go to an internet
cafe for to be even sadder right
internet cafe internet cafe I remember
we used to go there like I'm camped
field trips and like try and go on AIM
yeah well to our friends look legit the
markle's are your thirstiest they read
the standard for thirst they are a stain
on Buckingham Palace she's that there's
monster princess and like I just want to
know we need to have carried unity on
the show we really do like after the
Royal and I'm surprised he didn't post
about this you didn't know I didn't see
anything
oh your ponytail so coming to the side
do you know that because it's like my
hair was like bent it's had a rough
couple days I thought about in and out
of your side what do you mean like I see
it oh yeah it has a foot yeah very 80s
ever so brave
okay okay yeah no no like this is just
wild but yet it doesn't surprise me
because this we live in a disgusting
world where something as pure as mr.
Markel
being in an internet cafe reading up on
his daughter or having a book about
Britain like it's just it's too good to
be true I can't I honestly I was fooled
I feel like we are pretty skeptical as
it is yes and when I saw this I didn't
even question it didn't cross my mind
okay it was big and I actually
someone didn't say I forgot who it was -
probably Zack because he thinks
everything is fake he's like that's
totally fake and I was like how dare you
insult mr. Marco and they took me I'm
like how would mr. Marco get contact
with the photographer over there mr.
Marco insulting me like that it sounds
nice to my intelligence the seriously
[ __ ] you mr. Marco honestly and you know
what this is damaged they kept for me
this is damaging me son Ramsay because I
also believe that he Chu is what comes
up we would look through here in the
dictionary okay but you know what you
know who I blame
nearly mommy grand Megan why get your
family under control like seriously like
from the moment she got engaged she
hasn't been able to control her
half-brother her half-sister or her tab
like get it together you're marrying the
[ __ ] Prince you're not marrying some
random Joe Schmo where you can let your
family act like buffoons and no one
cares like the whole world is watching
you're clearly marrying up but get your
family under control so the Kensington
Palace had issued a statement like
asking the press to like back off of mr.
Marco at once the pictures came out not
the exposed ones but the ones they were
like please leave like give this man his
privacy meanwhile thirst monster father
thirst monster and a row wow that's
crazy and apparently he's gonna
apologize he's quote deeply embarrassed
Emel apologize for the paparazzi photo
storm says his son well his son also
says a lot of other things so who knows
if they're true I see him
the father yeah I believe that's the
father who's gonna vomit Jr I think his
son Megan's brother this is just too
much a head of the royal wedding like
it's crazy it's like I look forward to
this episode of the crown because I want
to know what's going on like what the
Queen is eternal in this moment does she
even give a [ __ ] like I feel like you
know there's some things that are on her
plate rage from Megan Marcos thirsty dad
- you know world wars of course so does
she even care that he's out here
embarrassing himself cine street world
wars don't really concern the Queen like
at this point because the Parliament
does that no but like she it's on her
radar you know and like she has to sit
down with it but she doesn't like really
have control no but like she could if
she wanted to as I've learned from the
Royals which season finale last night
and it was crazy and everyone should
watch the Royals it's an amazing show
everyone's beautiful might be able to
get me to watch Thai to see but you will
never get me I
watch the Royals it is the fakest
dumbest show but what I use I loved the
Royals and then I watched the crown
recently and then it went back to the
Royals and I was like these things would
never happen but I've gotten past that
and now it's just an amazing show
everyone's talking about elantra you
should I don't think you should watch it
just because I know you're like very
busy and like your CEOs mom and yeah his
schedules so busy so busy but I think
that everyone else out there would love
it there's a group of toasters question
where else and talk about it Oh like all
three of you throughout history also I
need to give a major shout-out to the
toaster so I got a really great email
this morning that because I partnered up
with Gift of Life which is the bone
marrow registry which I'm in the red
cherry oh yes no no I'm not okay sorry
I'm in the red night and I just wanted
to like let people know about gift of
life it's like the best organization and
I got an email today and what they told
me was that basically like on average
the bone marrow registry gets 25 to 30
new donors a week and the toasters came
out 300 new people put themselves in the
bone marrow registry which is so cool
we're gonna save some lives actually I'm
gonna save some lives because I got you
to do it so you're welcome that's so
nice
and actually was surprised to find how
many people have been like affected by
like bone marrow
yeah I've needed a donor for the donor
we're a donor yeah it's a cool the whole
process is super interesting I almost
signed up once but then I was like
sitting next to a nurse who told me not
to do it and that they were lying about
how painful it actually is well so back
in the day it used to be super painful
but like in recent years like it's not
it's not invasive anymore like yeah it's
a lot better oh you just have to Oh
someone told me so you don't have to do
like the surgery anymore but you have to
drink this stuff like the week before
that makes your bones like juicy like
ready for marrow and it makes you really
sore that's the painful part oh okay
that's better than something invasive
where they're like going to your your
back rib in like oh yeah no no I think
it's a lot better okay
I'm gonna sign up make 301 okay next up
we have a story in page six
um it comes off of a larger story but
basically how Anna Wintour is scheming
to revive Georgina Trotman career in her
final weeks
I don't whant or oh yeah okay well
Georgina Chapman was around the cover of
Vogue or was just a spread it was
Georgina Chapman is one of the founders
of Marchesa which was a popular fashion
house and was married slash technically
still married to Harvey Weinstein and
she did a tasteful spread in vogue that
was very much a puff piece very
flattering towards her very sympathetic
towards her how sad she is how she's
such a regular girl and her jeans and a
t-shirt and loafer and she know and she
didn't know and she so devastated for
the people and she recognizes that no
one will feel bad for at this time and
she's now she's trying to get her life
back on track
um well this is the thing everyone knows
Anna Wintour's on her way out
so in her final weeks I guess she's like
doing her friend a favor which is super
nice but like between her Georgina
Chapman and Meryl Streep like they all
knew and I'm just I'm sorry like I'm not
here for this lot for like this yellow
journalism yeah Anna Wintour is a
muckraker oh my choice okay when they
call Jughead America Waker and weirdos
that's my favorite word too because like
that's what are these days it's insane
it's muckraking like they write up what
they want to and like how they feel
about it it's not real like news and it
doesn't matter what like anyone else
think it doesn't matter what actually
happens okay but I have to be honest
like so when everyone was sending me
this Georgina Trotman thing I was like
not reading it she's complicit I don't
give a damn and then by the 12th time I
was like okay I'll read it and really
like I what she's trying to do like it's
kind of working because it really didn't
make me feel like what'd she say just
that you know she is so hurt by all of
it and she didn't know and she
understands that she does not allowed
people shouldn't feel sorry for her and
so like she's just kind of been like
taking time for herself and just staying
out of the public but like that you know
she deserves a chance I don't know and
that people should might mark as I can
okay
honestly like I think just what's the
part about it that like I think that
they glazed over
is that actresses were bullied into
wearing Marchesa and Marchesa was kind
of part of the Machine of this NASA
journey there is literally no logical
way that she did not know like sorry and
you could write the nicest piece that
you want but like I totally don't
believe in blaming a person for like
someone else's actions but like unless
you're complicit and you [ __ ] knew
there's no way she did not know really
if I knew what you know when Seth
MacFarlane made that joke at the Oscars
that did it alarm her right she wasn't
like oh why are they saying this about
me why are you saying that they're girls
locked up in my husband's basement why
are they saying that if these girls went
in Oscar they no longer have to pretend
to be attracted to Harvey Weinstein no
I'm like this is [ __ ] like serious
stop like I'm done like everyone Anna
Wintour is such like a self-righteous
garbage human and like this is [ __ ]
like sorry also apparently this isn't
the first time that Anna Wintour has
tried to like you know bring back her
friends from the from the dust so she'll
dead she did with John Galliano after
his drunken anti-semitic reading well I
mean she did it with a lint or hi you're
done go home with though there was I
read a piece I think was in the cut
about this piece and she did something
with Calvin climber he like posted an ad
that was like very like child
pornographic and she like totally
defended and even though like if you
were to watch it back now apparently
it's like skin and crawling okay
whatever I'm having I haven't watched it
back Lisa John Galliano's unforgivable
so she can kiss my ass for that reason
you're out bow is a joke I don't went
towards a piece of trash Marchesa its
garbage and everyone knew about it Meryl
Streep Anna Wintour and Georgina Chapman
can seriously get get a fork and eat my
ass oh so that is disappointing so star
joke Johansen more more monkeys on the
Met Gala right I guess like in an act of
solidarity and like I'm not here for it
yeah not here for it also like the dress
wasn't even that cute considering my
case that actually does make beautiful
dresses yeah like if you're gonna wear
Marchesa as a statement like please wear
the most beautiful one or yeah or don't
bother us
I'm not down and I love Scarlett
Johansson I think she's like really
smart but this is not cool you think
she's really smart with her boyfriend
who works two hours of media claudius
someone at SNL is watching the toast
because on Weekend Update this week they
had this girl who's a recurring like
character her name's like Bailey she's a
YouTube movie expert like where she
reviews movies and she's like really
awkward she's 12 and she's being weird
towards Michael che and she goes she's
talking to Michael che about how much
pressure she's under with her like
finals and everything she's like and
Michael che like I get it you work
really hard on Saturdays Chuck show
everyone watches the toast [ __ ] enews
tweeting out like justice for something
and we were like that's like I don't get
it twisted anytime the word justice for
something is used like sarcastically
like that is from us I don't want it to
get like twisted like nobody really
knows who the Kardashians really start
Oprah or was it going to be like no no
don't get it twisted
we started justice and anyone who uses
it it's stealing it from us and I'm
charging it and
know that we started it because we got
it from The Amanda Show so I know that E
news didn't get it from the Amanda like
No no one's talked about that line out
of the Amanda Show justice has been
starting to circulate in the last three
months because we started it about a
year ago right so don't get it twisted
every time you see justice for bling
tweet us fill in with justice for the
morning toast because they were robbed
of this yeah okay
we should trademark it okay okay next up
is Khloe Kardashian releases a photo of
True Jackson Thompson True Jackson VP /
one-month birthday this picture is
amazing cuz it's like someone so young
being the vice president of a fashion
house is really inspired right maybe she
should take over for Anna Wintour she's
super cute actually we need you Jackson
where's Kiki Palmer
I don't know but she would be fantastic
like Keke Palmer as should action no
Jackson true keke palmer you're
confusing me keke palmer is everything
everything right now
what did she work she doesn't fit as
much work as she should and then annoys
me yeah maybe she's not like thirsty
like the rest of them you know no she
definitely is really I love her and they
should really get they should do like a
VOC video of like True Jackson VP you
know how they do like Erika Jayne is an
intern for ya True Jackson
editor-in-chief okay wait I want to see
something about this picture of True
Jackson me say who I II who's really
pretty but why do the Kardashians always
like release photos of their kids with
filters on them it's like really [ __ ]
up I don't know I don't think it's
Africa first of all that's like just the
age that we're living in know her and
she I feel like it allows them to retain
like a little bit yeah of mystery
because like they their chemistry like
privacy yeah that like they're putting a
cute filter on their baby you don't get
to see like the baby and it's a natural
pure estate and like that's fine I feel
like it really suit public but it also
lets them keep like the you know
unfiltered versions for themselves true
is extremely cute and I want to say I
think she's cuter than stormy ooh I mean
I've never like gotten into comparing
babies that I love dream um I think all
babies are cute really and I think even
if you have a cute baby like it doesn't
even mean anything for what it's
actually gonna look like you know I mean
I'm literally like so gorgeous and I was
really ugly so so you just really never
so even if you have a like a cute baby
like the works not done yet
I'm just so down for the Kardashians
like not doing like People magazine
spreads like they're so above that and
they don't like need the money and it's
like awesome how they choose to use
social media for like their
announcements and they don't make like a
big huge brand to deal out of everything
like [ __ ] like even like a mal
Clooney like the yeah she donated it to
charity but she still was in People
magazine and George Clooney are so much
better than that do you think someone
commented that's that snapchat pays them
to use the filters and I do think that
snapchat pays them to stay on the
platform because there's only people
that haven't there are blinds they
definitely pay Kylie after she said that
thing really they lost over a billion in
like stock and now she's definitely a
paid ambassador um I don't know about
all the girls but for sure but they've
all they've started to use Instagram
stories now like a good amount will they
Kendall but they still but they haven't
left snapchat but but for a while they
were only doing snapchat and now they
have like an assistant uploading it to
Instagram stories but it's still what
the snapchat filters so like it's still
planted omage Instagram like I'm with
them like 100 percent they really have
to get back get on the filter train
right why you're not sleeping on it they
haven't gotten better
it's like also the even they have like
two cute filters like the dog and the
bunny but it changes your face so much
it's like way to fit square it's weird
you still look cute but it's like you
really look like you're trying to hide
something yeah it's just not as cute a
snapshot it's not like it's well
animated snapchat has the gold butterfly
filter back which is just divine yeah
like like that's that's magic you guys
do you believe in magic any young girl's
heart the music is free whenever it's
not sends magic if the music
we have no energy makes you feel happy
like in old town movie you want to see
no energy oh she's giving it all and
it's try to tell the soldier about a
rock and roll whoa part two to this
story is that Rob Kardashian is mad as
hell at Tristan and won't forgive him
for hurting Chloe Chloe okay like Chloe
only was like oh wow Rob Kardashian is
like the moral compass of the
Kardashians right like Rob Kardashian
I'm mad as hell at you for everything
you've done
everything we did to this family like
why didn't you go to Kim's wedding
because he got to the airport I got
paparazzi to my home yeah we know that
now but like so we people so short of
time I feel fat every single day like I
would never miss my siblings wedding
you know that's wild you have like no
family loyalty like to us like family's
everything and like look are we gonna
pin if like we missed like an hour of
someone's birthday like totally to miss
your own sister's wedding is wild and
proves like this so our family is
everything to so like he just he's
missing a chip a hundred percent like oh
my couldn't I can't even I told my
header but right so like whenever you're
starting to feel bad for Rob Kardashian
just remember he missed it was glad he's
met a twisted but like I'm sure Rob's
done worse to other people so like eat
my house totally like justice for
Adrienne Bailon is so much justice
give me them the whatever it's called
gavel sorry I'm trying to I'm making you
move it's really far away
order in the court so much justice needs
to be served for Adrienne Bilaam like
she was stripped of a life like the life
she could have had was skinny Rob
Kardashian and like made herself like an
honorary Kardashian like I so would have
been here for that life and she was
friends with the girls like any girl he
brings around like the girls hate so
imagine if they had a sister-in-law that
they actually liked okay not exactly and
I'm really happy from that she bounced
back because she really does have like
she's a great career now she's a great
healthy meal she's such a cute husband
named Israel like I love her but like
she could have had something a little
bit better and like I want justice for
the life she missed out on
I completely injustice like for us for
what we could have been seeing and
justice for Rob to like those old
episodes really by him really through
thick and thin literally there are
dreams yeah which is not run out with
Rob but like the girls and Adrienne like
those old episodes of Kardashian's where
they have that fake fight where like he
fake hits her in front of Chris and
Chris like did you just like that was
premium contest and honestly like for so
long I really saw that they were meant
for each other we're gonna get back
together and then what happened they
just didn't work out or he cheated on
her with you Rita Ora I think like a lot
of things happened and then there was
something that was just like the final
straw and she's like Rob was like hot
and like people like Rita or I wanted to
hook up but I remember when he had a
tattoo of Rita or on him and then he
gained weight and they said that now the
tattoo looks like a Cabbage Patch Kid
that's what Kim said yeah I never
thought about that what happens to
tattoos when you get fat to the stretch
they should cool we need to get skinny
Rob back I hear he's on his way home but
like I'm just really excited for skinny
Rob she wouldn't Emme he's nearby
longing for the real I think that's just
there's a lot of beef between the Rio
and the view and what about to chew in
the talk okay the true in the talk are
different what about actually the toilet
the view in the toast yeah these are the
view the real and the chew in the to
talk are all very similar and the view
the ladies claimed they said on an
episode that like they were the first
original format and like there's so many
copycats now and then the girls on the
real like fired back I don't know
actually I might be you is the original
format I believe right and
okay yeah so but like I don't know I'd
be more inclined to watch the real like
I like those girls better they're
funnier and they talk about [ __ ] like I
care about right and in the talk
question mark Sharon Osbourne that's all
I know about the talk I can't I don't
know how to keep him on and I do know
that like a while back they were like
casting for it and like my name was
brought up and I was like shaking like
obviously now like no one wants work
with me but whatever you didn't want to
do it any no because good to move and
also oh it's films in LA okay
all those shows are filmed in New York
I'm an Eastern Time maybe and also like
I think it would go like the toasts
obviously the view no I wouldn't I don't
think I would ever want to be I mean
just in terms of prestige oh yeah the
toast the view the real the real the
talk like the talk is so loveable they
get rid of sharing its like CBS just
like made one because like all the other
networks had and they like felt left out
right I think yeah well whatever
Congrats correct to AJ my LAN for ya
know I love her for rising above no I
think the argument had something to do
with the Emmy oh me they might they
hadn't any the end of you was like well
we really started this whole
conversation I don't like Inc if you're
not first you're last yeah how many guys
ever seen Ricky Bobby
and also like have you ever seen what is
that these necks I'm pretty sure show me
why that looks like my wedding menu is
it oh no it's I think it's Villa Blanca
Oh lol imagine I got married at Villa
Blanca oh this story is so sad you yeah
wait what were you about to say what was
I supposed to say we're in the middle of
a sentence before you saw this photo
what did the sentence sound like I don't
know something I know I have amnesia I
know I mean something about that oh I
mean let's me never forget what Barbara
Walters and the ladies of the view did
to Corey Feldman right so like they can
only my ass you need a spoon that's is
it a spoon or a fork well it depends
like what what's the what's being served
is like cheek is it
yeah he's it hold and yeah I guess it's
a spoon okay you know what let's just
out there she need a knife no I've got
resolved thank you okay so you need a
knife to spread it okay next three is
really sad so it's not laughing Lisa
Vanderpump's brother was reportedly
found dead in a suspected overdose she
said I am shocked and saddened
Lisa Vanderpump is mourning the
unexpected death of her only sibling
according to the Daily Mail the reality
stars older brother mark Vanderpump was
found dead at his home in Glau Chester
Shire England on April 30th after a
suspected drug overdose the British
Outlet reports the DJ was 59 it is
unknown whether the reported overdose
was accidental or deliberate according
to the report quote this has come as a
shock to us all my brother and I had
connected the day before this tragedy
and I was completely unprepared for this
Lisa 57 said in a statement to the
outlet he was my only sibling and I am
shocked and saddened by his passing I am
trying to be supportive to his two young
sons that he has left behind and helped
them get through this tragedy we
appreciate your consideration in this
private and extremely difficult family
time who knew she had a brother yeah cuz
I didn't and also like well there's a
lot of them together like on social
media and stuff so I guess if her family
like in terms of their age like really
confuses mesh he has two young sons and
he's was 59 and she like I'm how old is
she
Ken's Ken has like a 50 year old son who
has a wife who's like Lisa's age like
their whole family age dynamic makes no
sense they're a modern family for sure
Megan whatever old family yeah an
ancient family this is really sad are
they filming now no no they usually
start filming in like July that's the
other birthdays well if Lisa is coming
back the season which I think she might
not this will definitely be like a
storyline yeah I feel like actually I
feel like when something major like this
happens even though she's definitely
experienced tragedy before with like
nanny canes have it really like affects
your outlook I think that's why the Lisa
Rinna really like stopped getting so
involved in the drama because I just
lost her father and she does realize
what was important today so I feel like
if it maybe it affects how people like
our act on the show even like Jax we're
seeing now like yeah do you think him in
Brittany are engaged she wore like a
full like a fiancee ink diamond ring to
the sisters wedding in Michigan this
weekend but I don't know I wouldn't be
surprised even make a lot of sense and
what they would show it on the third
part of the reunion
I was forgot that we still have one more
that's right no this too makes the
second part
another mayhem of then there comes a
union that they just can't get under
control they need to take Bertie people
in and out it's like too many cooks know
there's like 30 people on that stage too
many bartenders at the bar it's like 13
yeah it's like that big photo that they
do but that photo that they take it for
the for the theme song every year like
has like faith in it like you ain't not
really but no but like every character
whatever even like walk through sir
Busboys every single salaries which is
good like its first run yeah
it's a restaurant to make family the
course some people who think need not be
on the rain and stage I got all times
Kristin Jodie totally Stassi she like
really wasn't involved I'm in a lot of a
dream you know times I've seen her
facial reactions but I agree she wasn't
invited stay Jackson Bernie should say
Tom should say Ariana man I don't even
know if Katie needs to say no Katie's
like the like the mom of the group kind
of right but like we haven't we barely
heard from think of who we should like
shift people in it should be like Lala
James scheana Ariana Tom's Hannibal do a
segment like yeah just keep rotating
people that's true it's really way too
many people and he's not even talking no
and Lala's asking the questions
yeah Lola is legit everything do you see
Lyle on can of course I did I that
mansion and her dress in like people are
agreeing that she is there because she's
being like Lala Emmett right now like
just why is Emmett she's mrs. mom I
can't come to the phone right now cuz
it's mrs. Emma right and she's living
her best life and I'm honestly so happy
we're also saying that she got married
cuz she's been wearing a wedding band oh
really
yeah I feel like she's gonna getting if
she's not already married I think they
might get engaged soon and I wouldn't
like jumping for joy
totally but then like she really like
wouldn't fit in on Vanderpump rules
because like she would be like this
married a matron like rich woman Cena
was married
Tommy Tom Ansari are married yeah
married to their equals
like right he's like so elevated they're
in can like do you know II mean but it's
just real housewife okay so either
she'll go to Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills or she'll stay like there's no way
she's not gonna be on TV you know but
I'm just saying like her getting married
would be everything but like then she
really would not fit in no but like
she'll still be pursuing like her lalla
Jane route you know doing here it's just
it's it would be bizarre it
our that she's like hosting at Sur
that's the only thing that's observed
but her working with James I'm totally
man I'm a bad nobody that I'm feeling
like I'm bailing you like a beer
showcase wasn't her outfit like in the
car on the back like and she's a good
dancer when she was like moving her hips
I'm like damn girl I absolutely love her
Lauryn Kent I love her so much I'm so
happy for her stories in can just army
and I'm so much like figured herself out
with the grip because like I think after
season one maybe or two she like was not
gonna come back no I know but Katie was
so mean to her it was insane yeah um
what else was on TV this week I'm so
excited for pump girls tonight Oh
American Idol I know you don't watch and
like I have was every single night I
turn I see on Saturday night I was on
it's on Sunday and my dates and they did
Carrie Underwood week so not only did
she performed with everyone she's saying
cry pretty and she looked way better
that's Jamie's amis in some pictures
she looks like her face is really jacked
up and then some pictures she looked
totally fine and on American Idol last
night like in a high definition she
looked great so I don't really know
what's going on
um and then they all say and Carrie
Underwood song oh no actually they
didn't I take that back I thought they
did but now they think about it that
girl saying Whitney Houston so no they
didn't it was just Carrie Underwood like
day I love Carrie Underwood know that
she embraces American Idol unlike the
person who has ran away
Oh to the boys you can run as far as you
want but running to the voice is like
heresy it is but it like I trust Kelly
hearts him in her decisions so like they
did they did her wrong and I and that
time was so hard for her what after she
went they were trying to like put her in
a box and like sing these songs that she
didn't want to sing and then she came
out with the worst album ever called
like my December yeah and then she
resurrected no end if we know anything
from Phillip Phillips inside American
Idol really makes you like when your
talent on American Idol who gets famous
they like own you for like years and
your songs they own everything about you
so I'm not surprised that like people
who were on American Idol don't have
like great relationships with them but I
think Carrie Underwood has a great
relationship with Fox because she does
that NFL so if she works like I just say
eat stop clapping got a real good
feeling about to happen
I mean stop climbing talking about it
that's the thing with the NFL yeah no
that's another song I was taught to do
the first Friday night Knicks on a mess
you know just how does an SL song go
that faithful thing um I don't know oh
it's so good
no that's still of those little write in
the comments yeah and then I think those
little that is the best thing ever
that's like made for the ladies you know
that for sure look for the girlfriends
who are sitting on the couch
no and it's my favorite part and her
legs are amazing biggest problem is that
they do that and then they do the
national anthem and then like all the
things I'm interested in are done with
like they need to show the halftime show
on TV it's not the Super Bowl even it
was just the cheerleaders happily and
they need to show more cheerleaders yeah
the FIR the unsung heroes of NFL right
they're just like yours I'm done with
people cheering cheerleaders
jenji on the cheerleading man what a hit
um also you know what I was thinking
about this is just random but you know
how like scripts and those networks that
like make home makers big careers like
Rachael Ray and the games in network
it's YouTube yes and they take a cut of
all of those problems like they own
those people it's weird how Real
Housewives and Bravo don't own part of
the business like if they had taken a
girl or it's a really good point I guess
they just don't expect any of them to be
successful and write that like my most
part they're not but like you would
think maybe like going forward okay we
know that we've made these huge brands
maybe we'll take a piece of it not that
I wanted to give them any ideas because
like these women should keep the money
if they are smart enough to make it
successfully interesting point you know
that's just something I was thinking
about right or like
AUSA caftan there was a girl at my show
in the VIP meet-and-greet who was
wearing a NASA caftan and she said it
was so comfortable how did it look be
honest it looks good it was like good
quality it looks like a Kyle Richards
they someone works around like good for
making that cop ten money hold on people
are writing the lyrics what is it uh
they're not being helpful but waiting
all day for Sunday night but
you know it yeah that's a real song with
Carrie Underwood ever in the liver which
is just like just like crazy why wasn't
Randall Lambert asked to sing on TV I
see maybe that's why I feel like Miranda
Lambert like it's just not about like
the NFL like capitalism you know no
she's on the south like no she I feel
like she wouldn't want to sell out to
the NFL oh yeah
better you sell out to the ACM taking
her song and having it like change the
words to like brilliant she's not about
that like why isn't blue Tacoma Toyota
commercial guys when I do think of a
real song after the show I'm going to be
so set
why is in blues become my swaiiowed a
commercial because they're not in tune
with what's next
Irish think likes attention like certain
brands like blue Tacoma is the Russell
Dickerson song which by the way to do
our music video just came out know and
like it was in partnership with
Firestone Tire it's like such a good
branded opportunity oh my god did you
hear rusty dick yes
rusty dick performed somewhere I don't
remember where and he mentioned me and
the toast on his stage you thankful
thing but what did you say so and then
another girl GM to me like uh like a
large so basically like he was talking
about like his nickname rusty decades
that girl's own job cause him that I
love her haha she's so funny and then
someone had a sign it's a toaster slob
rusty dick and then he was explaining
like the whole back story oh my god like
no
come January yeah it's hard with country
music I know that's why we're in CMA
fest hard is he performing I think so
you must be forming that I'm so excited
about Gavin DeGraw he's everything
justice for Gavin DeGraw know that song
soldier is the best but let's song Gavin
DeGraw every song what's so messed up
his brother like cool brother not hey
rather can it be your shelter it's with
a need to breathe to go when you always
do because just by the fest 5 yeah we
think it was five I didn't count but
yeah well that's it do you have any
parting things that you want to say to
my national show and follow me mister
you guys how I manage a room so close to
a hunter cake it smelled I'm like
getting nervous now what does it smell
like
it smells like success I love it you
guys you are truly the best you really
are Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time this is the morning chose
to tell your friends tell your peers
tell Sally at the water cooler
we're live on Facebook like us we're
live on YouTube subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up then we're also
available in the podcast app survey
that's five stars and tell everyone
about how beautiful we are
we love you we will see you tomorrow